حرب روسيا وأوكرانيا..
أزمة خبز تطلّ برأسها بالشرق الأوسط،
إذا كانت الحرب في الحدود الأوروبية الروسية
فلماذا قد يدفع العرب فاتورة هذه الحرب؟
وما الذي يعني دخول أمريكا وأوروبا لهذه الحرب؟
كيف سيستطيع العرب الخروج من
هذه الدوامة إذا أدخلوا إليها مجبرين؟
وأي صف سيختارون؟
هي أسئلة محيرة، وتزيد حيرة كلما
تعمقنا في هذه الحرب،
عندما تندلع الحرب هنالك دول عربية
هي الأكثر تضررا فما هي هذه الدول يا ترى؟
وما مدى تضررها؟
يبعث تصاعد التوتر في الأزمة الأوكرانية
على المخاوف في أوروبا والعالم بأسره،
من نشوب حرب مدمرة تنتج عنها كارثة إنسانية.
ماذا يعني ذلك لمنطقة شمال أفريقيا
والشرق الأوسط(أي الدول العربية تحديدا)
فإلى أي حد هي معنية بتطورات الصراع
بين الغرب وروسيا؟
تشكّل روسيا وأوكرانيا ما يصل إلى ثلث صادرات القمح
عالميًّا، يذهب الكثير من هذه الصادرات
للدول العربية تحديدا.
(ما هي الدول المتضررة؟)
يبدو أن عدة دول في الشرق الأوسط
وشمال إفريقيا هي الأكثر تضررا،
فهذه الدول مهددة بأزمة خبز جراء
التوترات بين روسيا وأوكرانيا،
حسب خبراء الاقتصاد،
فمع ارتفاع أسعار القمح عالميًّا أصبحت
مصر والجزائر في أعلى قائمة الدول المتضررة،
وتأتي بعدها  لبنان واليمن وليبيا وماليزيا
وإندونيسيا وبنجلاديش،
فهي  مهددة أيضا بارتفاع أسعار الخبز.
الضرر سيلحق بشكل أو بآخر بالدول الأخرى
كالسعودية والعراق وقطر والإمارات،،
هذه الدول التي ستدخل الحرب مجبورة
بمساندة هذا الطرف أو ذاك..
(السيناريو الأسوأ)
في الآونة الأخيرة، توجّه أكثر من 40%
من شحنات الذرة والقمح السنوية لأوكرانيا
إلى الشرق الأوسط أو إفريقيا،
كما أدّت موجات الجفاف التاريخية
في تلك البلدان العام الماضي إلى تفاقم الاحتياجات
من الحبوب مع ارتفاع أسعار المواد الغذائية المحلي..
وتمثل صادرات روسيا وأوكرانيا من القمح مجتمعة
206.9 مليون طن،
وفقًا للمزود الأميركي للبيانات "أس أند بي".
وفي هذا العام، من المتوقع أن تمثّل أوكرانيا
12% من صادرات القمح العالمية،
و16% للذرة، و18% للشعير، و19% لبذور اللفت.
الأزمة كشفت أهمية أوكرانيا.. كسلة غذاء مهددة!
تشكل أوكرانيا المصدر الرئيسي للقمح
إلى لبنان بنسبة حوالي 50 في المائة من احتياجاته،
و43 و22 في المائة من احتياجات كل من
ليبيا واليمن. وتبلغ نسبة واردات المغرب
من القمح 26 في المائة، وكذلك تستورد مصر القمح
بنسبة 50% من روسيا و30% من أوكرانيا،،
وهي نسبة تضع أوكرانيا كمصدر رئيسي للبلاد العربية.
أما الجزائر فان روسيا هي المزود الرئيسي
من القمح وتليها أوكرانيا، بينما تراجعت
مكانة فرنسا مؤخرا كمزود بالقمح للسوق الجزائرية،
بسبب التوتر في العلاقات.
(أسواق السلاح)
وفي السنوات القليلة الماضية قامت روسيا
بخطوات لاستعادة مكانتها في دول عربية
كان لديها نفوذ فيها أيام الاتحاد السوفييتي سابقا،
وشكلت صفقات الأسلحة الطريق المعبد
لتحقيق هذا الهدف.
ففي الجزائر ضاعفت روسيا صادراتها من السلاح
للبلد العربي الكبير، وحافظت على وضعها
كأول مزود للجيش الجزائري الذي يُخصص له
سنويا ما يناهز 10 مليارات دولار يذهب معظمها
إلى صانع السلاح الروسي.
وفي العراق،
استعادت روسيا دورها كمزود بالسلاح رغم ما حدث
من تحولات بعد الغزو الأمريكي للبلد
وإعادة بناء الجيش وتسليحه من الولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها الغربيين...
بينما يتجه الخليجيون لشراء السلاح الروسي
لعدم وجود شروط عليه كالسلاح الأمريكي
الذي ينظر في الحالات الإنسانية كما يحدث في اليمن...
(بدائل الغاز الروسي)..
تعتبر الجزائر هي مورد الغاز الرئيسي لكل
من إيطاليا واسبانيا
وثالث أكبر مصدر للغاز الطبيعي
للاتحاد الأوروبي بعد روسيا والنرويج،
وكما يمكن لقطر أن تغذي أوروبا بالغاز
لكن هذا يعني تركها للمستورد الأول لغازها
وهي الصين. لكن ذلك يمكن أن يؤثر سلبيا
على علاقات الجزائر مع حليفها التقليدي روسيا
وكذلك على علاقات قطر بحليفتها الصين.
كل ذلك قد يجعل الدول العربية في مرمى نيران
روسيا وحلفاءها..
والشيء الوحيد الذي يمكن أن يمنع روسيا
من القيام بذلك هو أن تظل دول الخليج مورداً
رئيسياً  للنفط والغاز للصين الصديقة لروسيا،
لكن هذا يعني رفضها لواشنطن في محاولاتها
لاستبدال الإمدادات الروسية في أوروبا.
وهذا يعني صراعاً حاداً بين هذه الدول وواشنطن،
وربما انقلاباً أو احتلالاً.
بطريقة أو بأخرى، لا يمكن للدول العربية في الخليج
إلا أن تختار، وسيتعيّن عليها اتخاذ هذا الخيار
في وقت مبكّر عن دول العالم الأخرى.
بل وسيكون هذا الاختيار صعباً للغاية.
قد لا يكون من باب المصادفة أن تعلن روسيا اليوم
في خضم الاهتمام العالمي بأزمة أوكرانيا،
اعتزامها إجراء تدريبات بحرية في البحر المتوسط،
وأنها نقلت قاذفات وطائرات مجهزة بصواريخ
أسرع من الصوت إلى قاعدتها الجوية في سوريا.
ويعد هذا من المؤشرات الدالة على أن منطقة
الشرق الأوسط وشمال أفريقيا هي بمثابة قطعة
من رقعة شطرنج عالمية تتجاذب حولها الأدوار
وصراع النفوذ بين القوى الكبرى.
وستكون مصر والجزائر والمغرب،
هي الدول التي ستتأثر أكثر في حالة قيام حرب
بين روسيا وأوكرانيا... فكيف سيكون حال العرب
في هذه الحرب اللعينة؟